nicolas t'as bu les sondages
ça va bien des sondages et la
manipulation des sondages les sondages
ça va et vient c'est comme la queue du
chien fossoyeur du jeu démocratique
fabricant du scrutin ou tout simplement
inutile les sondages sont souvent mis
sur le banc des accusés à la proche de
chaque échéance électorale pour autant
ils sont aussi considérés comme un
instrument indispensable pour analyser
la diversité des opinions politiques
depuis 1965 et la première élection au
suffrage universel alors vont-ils
jusqu'à influencer les électeurs dans le
choix de leur candidat réponse dans
facture
[Musique]
la publication de très nombreux sondages
répond d'abord et avant tout à cette
idée d' essayer d'éclairer plus une
volonté qui au fur et à mesure des
élections présidentielles n'a cessé de
s'amplifier selon la commission des
sondages chargée de contrôler les
enquêtes publiées le nombre de sondages
ayant un rapport direct ou indirect avec
l'élection présidentielle était de 111
en 1981 un chiffre en constante
évolution depuis
293 en 2007 409 en 2012 et jusqu'à 560
en 2017 alors évidemment écrit
république ne veut pas dire non plus
vouloir lui forcer la main aux vouloir
l'obliger à changer de foie de boeuf par
exemple pour empêcher que les sondages
électoraux ne vienne perturber les
élections présidentielles et surtout
influencé les électeurs ils sont
encadrés par la loi du 19 juillet 1977
modifié quatre fois entre 1990 et 2010
est cette loi interdit par exemple la
publication de sondages d'opinion en
rapport avec l'élection présidentielle
la veille et le jour de chaque tour de
scrutin elle oblige également les
instituts a indiqué la marge d'erreur de
chacun de leurs sondages
ça montre un peu la limite de
l'interprétation des sondages
ça ne sont que des sondages battre a dit
la tradition veut tandis qu'un sondage
c'est une la faune photo à un moment un
instant t et que ce qui est vrai
aujourd'hui ne sera pas vrai le jour de
l'élection l'influencent des sondages
sur les électeurs restent sujets à
débats malgré cette réglementation et la
question est étudiée depuis leur
apparition au début du 20e siècle en
2005 dans les cahiers du cevipof lionel
marc qui offre un bilan très complet de
ses recherches et met en avant quatre
effets qui sont imputés aux sondages
électoraux le premier d'entre eux et les
faydits band wilde ou de contagion qui
pousserait les lecteurs a porté son
choix sur le vainqueur désigné par les
sondages en 2010 est par exemple lors de
l'élection présidentielle il est évident
qu'une part non négligeable de les
victoires de centre gauche cros baptisé
par le renoncement de françois hollande
qui est décidé de ne pas être candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
pas convaincus par la campagne par la
primaire et par la campagne de benoît
hamon qui ne voient pas que l'europe est
en train de se disloquer au fond on va
voter soit mélenchon pour sauver
l'honneur de la gauche est d'avoir un
candidat de gauche je vois le plus haut
possible soit va se rabattre sur
emmanuel macron au titre qu'il a été
ministre de françois hollande est que à
l'époque emmanuel macron à une image un
peu plus centre gauche c'est le cas
aujourd'hui le second effet est appelée
underdog wa outsiders
il conduirait à soutenir le candidat ou
le camp donné perdant il est ainsi
possible que des électeurs est envie de
se porter au secours d'un candidat en
perdition dans les sondages pour des
raisons d'attachement à sa personnalité
à ses idées ou encore à son parcours
politique lors de l'élection
présidentielle de 2002 le socialiste
lionel jospin en tête des sondages juste
derrière jacques chirac et certains
d'atteindre le second tour et pourtant
jean marie le pen finit par le devancer
d'un petit pour cent à la surprise
générale le résultat du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle
qui vient de tomber et comme un coup de
tonnerre dans le fameux 21 avril 2002 il
y a eu des effets de ce genre d
électeurs de gauche pensant que lionel
jospin était déjà qualifiée au 2e tour
ont voté avec leur coeur pour des
candidats de gauche dont il savait qu'il
n'avait aucune chance d'atteindre le
deuxième tour ou de gagner l'élection
présidentielle et donc on a vu du vote
chevènement david du vote taubira le
troisième effet mis en évidence entre
dans la logique du vote dit utile ou
stratégiques il veut qu'un certain
nombre d'électeurs reportent leurs
intentions de vote sur un candidat
qu'ils apprécient moins que leur
candidat favori mais qui selon les
sondages a de meilleures chances de
gagner le second tour d'une élection
tous les scrutins il rajoute utile on
essaye d'avoir la date d'avoir de faire
en sorte que les électeurs de son camp
ce vote se reportent en masse sur sur
soi dans ce cas là pour que pour que est
porté par par par cette cet effet de
vote utile c'est vrai que cette
problématique pas se poser a beaucoup
d'électeurs en particulier de la droite
en 2022 si la trajectoire des intentions
de vote d'aujourd'hui continuer à se
confirmer nul doute que du côté des
sympathisants des électeurs du
rassemblement national ce qu'eric
zemmour et de valérie pécresse on aurait
beaucoup à cogiter sur la question du
vote stratégie le dernier effet imputé
aux sondages qui presque une critique et
son influence supposée sur l'abstention
des électeurs lors du second tour de la
dernière élection présidentielle
un électeur sur quatre ne s'est pas
déplacé pour départager marine le pen et
emmanuel macron un taux d'abstention
record qui aurait pu être causée par les
sondages unanimes sur la victoire du
candidat la république en marche c'est
l'un des grands reproches qu'on fait aux
sondages c'est d'établir d'établir à
l'avant ça vainqueur et ça pourrait
inciter certains à certains ne pas se
rendre au duo pense qu'avec si
l'élection donne le sentiment d'être un
peu trop couru d'avancé ça va pas
motiver les lecteurs par contre une
élection qui semble très serré
normalement va polariser va mobiliser
chacun des deux camps puisque chacun des
deux camps et le sentiment que peut-être
une seule voix pure et la différence
après avoir décrypté ces phénomènes nous
sommes désolés de vous dire que ces
quatre effet donne des résultats assez
faible voire contradictoires on estime
aujourd'hui qu'un quart des électeurs
fait son choix dans la dernière ligne
droite de la campagne au moment où les
sondages sont moins nombreux une
dernière chose cruciale prendre en
compte les électeurs orientent leur
choix de vote principalement en fonction
de considérations idéologiques de valeur
de croyance d'attitude dans lesquelles
il croit profondément donc ce soir des
déterminations de long terme mais il ya
vie la mort les déterminations de court
terme et penser détermination de m et
bien la tonalité de la campagne et les
sondages participe directement et
indirectement à la formation du choix